did you know i think 60 years ago women
couldn't vote yeah you know that's wrong
yeah it's wrong it's also there's
somebody put a clip on
like in the last 40 years a montage of
white and black and other comedians
making fun of asians but they put it in
a clip right where it's like a montage
right
and it's like it when you clip them
together it seems racist it seems like
you know not you know
culturally right you know but it's like
i always put in the context of comedy
and the way it's grown like when i
started comedy in the 90s there wasn't a
lot of people that looked like me doing
it i had margaret cho maybe a couple of
other people right joe and i that's coy
and i met at open as open micros back in
the day right but we were the only ones
and it's like um
and i saw it live i would see and i
laugh because i'm a comic and stuff like
that but it's like i don't blame people
for doing jokes but there was a time
where the go-to
um panacea for not being in trouble it's
a joke yes or i'm joking or it's part of
the act and they kind of took that away
yeah you can't joke about it there is no
joke yeah
and sometimes it is a joke because it's
wrong yeah that's why
it's inappropriate i'm saying something
that i know is inappropriate yeah i'm
standing here naked dancing in front of
strangers in my underpants because it's
it you wouldn't do it you know the
audience and the reason why we're afraid
and we change with the times is because
we're afraid to lose
everything
and so i'm just gonna tell you that
there i have been thinking to myself
if i let go of corporate stuff like you
know right now i'm going to new york to
do um sex in the city a couple episodes
right i just did that movie i have other
things coming out and i don't want to
lose those things so what happens is
that i
change right and i you know um
sell out in a way yeah right and the
freedom's gone right so there's got to
be
to me it's like should i just say f all
that and just be myself and not worry
about you know me what i'm i don't know
or not you're thinking it's like you're
reading my mind because the thing about
it is i wasn't i had we've talked about
this on other shows but i had a rough
time and you do we talk about this
mentally you know mental health and um
my greatest
uh outlet when i found comedy because i
felt like being having this kind of
character and blurting out things and
saying things and acting
like we act it i i don't think you could
imagine either one of us in a corporate
job in a real corporate job like sitting
in a and we wouldn't last we probably
wouldn't get along with people we would
be frowned upon whereas you're kind of
you know celebrated as being a comedian
but now even in the world of comedy
everything that made me happy and
comfortable this was the place i used to
say
when i was on you know i was an actor i
was on
you know a a television show or i was
hosting a game show people would say
what do you like best and i'd say stand
up because stand up is the one thing
where i didn't have to memorize a line i
didn't have to hit a mark i didn't have
to worry about sponsors i didn't have to
worry about offending there was no place
i couldn't go and stand up and i love
that freedom
gone it's gone
and um
but is it
that's what i'm do it isn't you know
because i know guys yeah like i think i
can say his name there's this guy named
brian holtzman okay for instance he has
no grand dream of being in a movie or
hosting a show
but on stage he's the freest guy i've
ever seen because he says anything he
wants
right and he's not a slave to
corporations he doesn't care
right so you and i both we were that no
but we were that
when we started out yes
but as you've accumulated like i don't
want to get in trouble with agt you
don't want to you want to do these
movies
so that never played when we didn't have
anything it was kind of easier it was
easier there was so much freedom and
like i would say really crazy things but
i had nothing to lose i had no money i
had nothing right right now i have a
house you know what i mean i got dogs
you know i got
cars i got no matter what you say you're
not gonna lose your dogs
you won't they don't that's it yeah did
you see that you said
bobby lean is underpants i'm taking away
his [ __ ] dogs
because those things need a bone and
there's just a little yellow thing but
it's it's not only you're talking about
corporations and other jobs and income
and stuff like that but it's not only
that i know at least for you you're very
worried and concerned about also
offending people like you don't want to
offend anyone no and you didn't used to
have to worry about that or at least you
weren't aware of having to worry about
that right right and now it's not only
agt or movies or television or sponsors
it's also that for you isn't it yeah i
don't want people to be hurt there was
no you know
you used to be able even off stage you
know if you said something and somebody
took offense and they go what did you
just [ __ ] say and you go i was joking
that was okay yes not doesn't fix it
anymore
yeah but it's like
but it's the people
how do i say this i don't know why but
i've always like i've been on stage in
the audience before and seen a comic
say things about asians right that are
so offensive like if you just read it
right yeah but because i know i'm in a
comedy club setting i know that it's you
know we have first amendment rights you
can say whatever you want right and i
know the context that's
have you ever seen something that you
felt offended in no because i've seen it
all i've seen comics make fun of our
penis and sizes i've seen comics make
fun of our accents i've seen comics do
every range you know i mean i've had
comics say i'm sorry say [ __ ]
right or [ __ ]
right but they say it in the context of
comedy and by being in the audience
because i know my skill level i know
that i can defend myself i know how good
i am in the world what if you were
sitting in the room with your mom
well it's like i wanted to i watched um
gran turismo is that the movie with my
mom
the cleanest
and it's like clint eastwood says some
crazy things and i i was i kept looking
at my mom
because i thought maybe she'd be
offended by the movie and she was just
like it's it's you know it's a movie
and it's true i mean there are people
out there like that and this is an old
immigrant woman right she even gets that
like you know it's just you're when
you're watching a movie it's just a
splice of
a segment of society we may not have to
agree with it right but still
you know a movie right it's an art form
right stand-up is the same thing
well that's why you know even as a
stand-up there is never anything that's
too soon yeah you know they always but
now there
is yeah for the audience for the
audience but if you and me weren't even
on a podcast the things we could say and
the things we could do are so different
than what you're allowed to do with a
microphone in front yeah me and andrew
did an experiment
and we said let's do one podcast we're
never gonna air
and he goes okay we can say whatever we
want
we talked for three hours
and i had never like i was crying for
three hours laughing so hard you would
never we would never release it we would
we would never have careers
it is crazy what comes out of our mouth
i mean it's insane it's like but we did
it for
us
to exercise our rights to say
things in this country because we live
in america
right and um well
we will we said we'll release over 10
million dollars
i think we can delight in ours and go
nft what sell it as an nfp
right yeah yeah but it's really freeing
you know and you know
hopefully one day we'll live in a world
where we can release it
[Music]
you